[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
April 20th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
to address their employees mental health
some companies are offering workers
additional days off and in some cases
giving the entire staff days off we're
joined by Wall Street Journal
contributor Tara Weiss so Tara dealing
with mental health in the workplace it
isn't something new anyone who's been a
working person knows that this is not a
new thing dealing with the outside world
can obviously impact you on your
day-to-day basis you don't turn off your
personal life when you log onto your
computer but I do think that the
difference here is that employers are
acknowledging it and so we really
started seeing these policies come into
place I'd say in about 2020 after George
Floyd was murdered by a Minneapolis
Police Officer as a result employers
started to think about how they could
help and support these employees whether
it was offering mental health trauma
counseling on company time and on the
company dime and from there they
realized that they didn't want to
prescribe how somebody has to deal with
these stressful events that are
happening and so they decided to allow
employees to figure out how they wanted
to deal with this on their own and
that's when we started seeing these paid
days off in addition to sick days and
personal days
so Tara you alluded to steps companies
are taking to revamp their time off
policies what are they doing there to
address workers Mental Health
some are offering extra personal days
um to do whatever they want to do and
recharge however they see fit others are
offering paid time off to do volunteer
work and then some companies are sort of
relegating a day off each quarter the
whole company shuts down so that
everyone at the company doesn't feel the
pressure to respond to an email or to
get some work done despite the fact that
it's a designated day off
one reason they're doing this is because
they don't want employees to worry that
they'll come back to an even bigger pile
of work okay but at many companies it
just isn't possible to give the whole
staff a day off and definitely not on
short notice so how are companies
addressing mental health and burnout but
short of giving the whole staff a day
off sure so companies are designing
respite rooms these are places to wind
down to come and to focus if you've had
a negative interaction with a colleague
or a particularly stressful event happen
at the office or even outside of the
office this is a place where you can
come and just decompress they often
feature a soft color palette biophilic
design that would incorporate nature
like plants
sounds that you might hear in nature and
you're not allowed to bring your phone
in there you're not allowed to bring
your computer in there they don't want
this to become a place where people go
to have a quiet work area that's not the
concept and then at some places like
Adobe for instance they have a craft
room and that's meant not only to
decompress but also to really get the
creative juices flowing for people who
feel like they need to get their energy
out Adobe also has an outdoor basketball
court in its Seattle office
at its headquarters in San Jose
California there are meditation pods
private music rooms where you can plug
in whether it's music that you want to
listen to with headphones or if you want
to play say an electric guitar you can
plug that in with headphones so you
won't disturb anyone else wow and have
these gone over with workers are they
working I think that this is a great
perk for workers particularly when we're
in a tight labor market unemployment is
still at pretty historic lows and so if
someone's offering you a job where you
can take a time out and go into a
meditation pod that sounds pretty great
to me Jr we're on the wrong line of
business yeah
but it is a good idea if you can kind of
take some alone time and just sort of
reset your thoughts right yes
sources where we joked in a really sort
of sardonic way because so many of us as
employees of a certain age have had an
experience where we've gotten really
upset from a negative interaction with a
colleague or maybe we failed on a
project and we've gone into the bathroom
to cry
I think for people of a certain age
we've all had that experience and so
many of my sources talked about that you
don't have to cry in the bathroom
anymore that's what so many of these
rooms are really being designed for to
have a place where you can go and be a
human have a human reaction and not feel
like you have to hide it and also where
it's accepted but it seems like the
addition of these rooms and policies
have come fast and furious especially in
the last couple of years how does that
make the older generation of workers
feel so the older generation many of
them have said to me why can't they just
sort of buck up and deal with it we had
to deal with it why can't they deal with
it but there's no question that kovid
had an impact on the workplace and that
the walls between work life and home
they really came tumbling down during
the height of the pandemic when so many
of us had to work from our apartments
and our houses and we saw a more human
side of our managers of our co-workers
and that in some sense is a direct
reflection of that all right so what's
in this for the companies why is it
important for them to take these steps
to address their workers mental health
there's a growing body of evidence that
shows that people who are suffering from
burnout anxiety they're going to quit at
higher rates they're not going to be
completely engaged with work there was a
pretty significant Gallup study that
came out some months ago that talked
about worker disengagement is at its
highest levels ever and so if employers
want to get their best work out of
people they're going to have to
understand that mental health impacts
the way that you work on a daily basis
you know Tara you mentioned the
importance of retaining and attracting
employees in a tight labor market the
companies typically advertise the fact
that they offer these mental health
initiatives so companies aren't putting
these in job advertisements but by the
time that you get to a job offer this is
going to be discussed in the benefits
packages and by the time you get to that
point especially if an employee is
deciding between this job and another
job it's absolutely going to be
something that they share with their
prospective employees all right that's
Wall Street Journal contributor Tara
Weiss thanks so much for being with us
and that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
foreign